and welcome back everyone an agenda
Gillian pocket dink dink dink dink dink
dink dink dink talk about some cool [ __ ]
today that everyone wonders every day of
their life maybe they don't I don't know
we do we oh yeah
it's cool it's this episode is brought
to you by ring video doorbell system
guys ring video doorbell system right
here love I it is the dopest there is a
home burglary every 13 seconds don't be
a victim okay guys the ring video
doorbell system has been proven to stop
burglaries before they happen
they have camera monitoring right to
your phone it's pretty incredible right
now you guys can get up to 150 dollars
off the ring of security kits by going
to ring.com slash jana Julian it's also
brought to you by texture texture is the
new way to read magazines guys you get
it all on your phone on the text or app
tons and tons of magazine choices
curated right on your phone for you or
your tablet really awesome way to read
your favorite magazines right now you
can get a free trial with texture go by
going to texture coms last Jena Julian
that's texture cop slash I'm Julian
thank our sponsors more on them later
okay so all right Julie first of all can
we sidetrack for one second and exactly
your blog and I talked about my snapchat
but people were freaking out at me the
other day because it's really cute I
said I wanted to shave my eyebrows and
so I did I shaved half my eyebrow the
outside half because I just wanted to
make a different tail shape it's not
even the first time I've done it and
people were like DMing Julian and
damming Rome and like tweeting it Rome
like is Jenna okay I think I went full
Britney Spears yeah there's not a
different tail shape fam you know I
think they came out cute the card ball
right I'm being perfectly honest I'm in
that party well I like when I saw that
picture like people were tweeting at me
I was like what are you what is she
doing my name is down cuz I've never
even heard of that like I didn't know
it's just something I didn't know about
you something shaped their whole eyebrow
yeah I just didn't know about it so I
saw a dubgame DM is Jenna okay so her
family about what are you talking about
yeah she's fine she's upstairs doing her
makeup thank you
um but you look cute and I like it and I
like the purple Thanks I think it's fun
and exciting and Marvel needs to shut
his mouth Marvel know he's don't get got
son yeah I'm fine my eyebrows are fine
but thank you for your concern thank you
for your concern she didn't go Britney
Spears girl Britney Spears so what
happens after you die
that's what we're going to talk about
that's where we're going but not like in
a morbid ways we just want to look up
some theories and yeah and just kind of
like blow our minds yeah so I went dead
of some yeah it's all about okay well so
were you raised religiously at all it
was I raised you know so you weren't
taught like anything about what happens
after you die your grandparents or does
your family have any specific traditions
about burying people or cremating people
sending them off into a Viking ship and
lighting out fire with bow and arrow
into the ocean well no nothing specific
honestly and you know that yeah you know
I've been to multiple funerals and some
of my family and good there's not as
long as I know as far as I know like
there's no certain theme or or practice
or religious way of doing it but I know
that a lot of people in families have
certain ways because their religion and
tradition and whatnot but we really just
kind of wanted to talk about like the
different theories of like literally
what happens when you die what is maybe
what your personal theory is if you had
wonder if you were brought up with one
like right now if you were to ask me
what what I think happens well I don't
know I was just more asking I guess what
you were brought up or taught by your
family to be honest there isn't
something that I can remember that I was
taught specifically I was taught heaven
in hell okay because of church yeah
literal just hell yeah yeah that's about
it yeah I mean honestly I would say that
I was taught that but that's not from
being raised religiously is just from
like watching movies you know like
that's kind of what you see and stuff
anyway we I'll probably have a better
understanding of them of what I believe
after we go through some of these
I'm excited I am excited - we got a lot
of these I got this source called what
culture calm there's a list it was
really helpful and let's start at the
bottom no it's out of the top the
universe brain theory so that theory is
that the universe is a brain the whole
universe is just one brain and every
single person in the universe or every
single thing or person sentient is just
a cell inside the brain and once that
brain cell dies like a person dies it
gets excreted out of the brain like a
light them getting screaming yeah like a
dead brain cell because you lose cells
all the time like your cells die on so
when you die you get extreme you know
excreted what does that mean you get
pushed out but into matter can't be
created or destroyed so where does it go
I'm not it's not put it's not destroyed
it's excreted it's it's moved away from
the brain positive whole universe is the
brain the where does it go outside the
universe but that doesn't exist if the
universe is the brain if the universe is
a brain the brain exists in some sort of
if you ever sided to you that's what I'm
saying like maybe it's another world or
another universe or another I don't know
I'm not buying that one I'm about
knowing at all well you're just a brain
cell you don't have you don't get to buy
anything I don't I don't like that one
either I don't like that that one's kind
of whatever but you know we're just
getting started so calm the [ __ ] down
everyone right the reincarnation theory
I'm sure everyone has heard of this one
mmm
your consciousness leaves your body when
you die and move somewhere else in the
universe you could be reincarnated
reincarnated as a human an alien a
sentient ocean of water on earth or
elsewhere I've never heard that that you
could be reincarnated as a sentient
ocean of water
no it's Sciences so you're saying that
oceans have souls I'm not I'm not just
I'm literally just reading the theory
okay no keep reading No
and then it was like you could be a
human an alien
a whole planet you could be reincarnated
as a fly a plant kind of anything I've
been aiming too low like whenever I
think about reincarnation I'm like I
would love to be like a cat cat or a dog
because be an ocean and get spoiled Oh
[ __ ] I want to be a planet when I get
reincarnated I want to be actual Pluto I
guess the question of like when you
reincarnated like what are the
stipulations for what needs to be your
new housing for your soul or your herbs
you know whatever your brain you know
your thoughts well my only thing about
reincarnation is like where do you draw
the line of what gets reincarnated not
like does bacteria get reincarnated
that's that's also I'm saying like
what's the rule book here well I don't
get to be reincarnated and when you do
get reincarnated what are you allowed to
be reincarnated as oh my god Marvel okay
so say if you if it was just a theory of
consciousness if a being has
consciousness it can be reincarnated but
then how can a sentient body of water
get reincarnated whatever whatever but a
tree doesn't have consciousness but I've
heard that you can be reincarnated into
a tree is it just something that's
living so it's a carbon matter maybe
that's kind of what I thought so any
carbon matter gets reincarnated maybe
then maybe that's why maybe the
collection of souls on earth right now
are the same collection of souls that
have ever existed on earth just mostly
being really back tyria in your body is
also a soul and every bacteria has been
reincarnated as more bacteria or
something else what's disgusting though
like thinking about your body like the
some of your body is made up of like
hundreds of thousands of dead people or
this is thousands of dead people
I make sense marbles right like it's
buddy mowed their lawn one day and it
turned into marble yeah yeah that's
crazy or that giant ocean the Atlantic
Ocean triggered a period living like
fish and all kinds of stuff in
Algie you're telling me LG gets
reincarnated maybe I'm but I would buy
into the theory that things that have
consciousness is consciousness
consciousness that's definitely I would
say I would say that should be a
requirement to but how do you get
reincarnated into a body of water that's
not alive if it's sentient do this yeah
I don't know about that that one was
weird to me that yeah I got a good grasp
on reincarnation until you just said
that mm-hmm what the [ __ ] well I was
part of the you know the the article
that listed that theory that the
reincarnation theory obviously the
reincarnation theory is no new new
theory Danny when everyone's heard of it
but maybe that little stipulation kind
of opens up the conversation to what is
allowed to be reincarnated or what you
are allowed to be reincarnated as which
I think it well I mean I want to know
because if I'm go get reincarnated one I
die and this is out of my control I
would like to say whether or not I get
to be a planet or sentient body I'm sure
that one of the things about being
reincarnate is yoga to choose really
though really well so is it maybe based
on like your karma from that lifetime I
think it's based on that and a lot of
other things like karma the people that
you interacted with in this life the the
impact you made on certain other people
in that light like I think it's how you
live your life like you could be born
one way or one like person and the way
you die is kind of the path that's going
to take you into the next being so this
is going to sound morbid but if you dies
as a child you're going to be
reincarnated something completely
different than if you were to die as an
old person who has lived an entire life
with an entire life full of decisions
and people met and experiences yeah no I
agree with that no like if you were a
really shitty person you would get
reincarnated as I would imagine
something not as fun or awesome guys
okay well here's a question so do you
think that a person because maybe this
is a bigger question but a person is
sort of like what you would like to be
reincarnated into
like is this the highest level of
reincarnation I don't think the person
is the highest level yes thank you yeah
I feel like just you know we talked
about aliens and [ __ ] and people who say
that they don't believe in you know
anything happening after you die I'm
okay with that but it's the people that
are like totally theists that are like
no people are the top of everything
we're the top of the top the best has
ever been and you know there's no higher
being there's no higher energy like to
me that is the most self-centered way to
think of the universe in the world like
there is no other higher more
narcissistic version of viewing life
than that that's all it is it's not even
really really you think that were the
universe's greatest creation us boy
there really is no other better
adjective for it other than narcissistic
because like for you to think even for
one second that you and your species is
the VL and all of human exists or
anything existence in the entire
universe like the fact that you're
making that statement literally just
shows that your thought process
everything that you've ever known
revolves around you and your species and
like you may not be some you know alien
researcher or someone who's gone outer
space or someone who literally knows you
know what what to look at in terms of
like the facts of why we are not the
only existing you know species in in the
in existence but just to know that there
are a lot of a lot of like there's a lot
of I don't know I'm trying to like get
to a point like there's light-years and
light-years and light-years of space and
that's just one little subsection of the
entire universe and you know the bigger
picture of everything and we are so
miniscule on that and you don't need to
be smart to know that yeah well I just
like it's not that I have a problem with
atheists in and of themselves I have I
have a problem with the atheists that
are aggressive who are aggressively like
we're the best thing in the whole
[ __ ] universe and there is no God and
then when you die [ __ ] [ __ ] everything
imagine though like if a brain cell is
saying that and then he just
like dies and gets excreted out of the
giant brain yeah well I don't know this
is in your theories but I think that it
is a possibility that whatever you truly
believe the afterlife is or whatever you
think happens to you when you die
happens to you so that means everyone
can be having their own a through life
well maybe like if you live your entire
life and you're like dude nothing
[ __ ] happens when you die and then it
just goes black and [ __ ] duh science
that's what happens to you and you die
but if you believe that you'll be
reincarnated
you'll get reincarnated if you belong to
haven't you got to have it I mostly
disagree with us I agree with you I'm
like a little portion of that in the
sense of like I disagree that would not
be the universe being like all right
dude well [ __ ] you want it would be but
I don't think it's like that I think I
think people will have different
afterlife's
you know not everyone has the same
afterlife but I think it's more based on
like the afterlife you have which is an
afterlife for everyone here some people
are just not going to not not have
afterlife's like everyone's going to get
one but I think it's very heavily based
on the life that you lived yeah no I see
I agree with that that's that's my other
problem people that believe in nothing
higher than people or humans or you know
the people that reject anything what I
called a good nihilist or something so
you have you have like no social
conscious because you think nothing
matters that life doesn't even [ __ ]
matter there's nothing's going to happen
when you die whatever it's hard for me
to live my life not like feeling like I
don't have to answer to a higher power
when I die you don't I mean like I do
think that you will be held accountable
for the decisions and the choices that
you make in your life in one way or
another and it was not walking up to a
man it's like he's going to be yeah
karma or someone you know Judgment Day
or some sort of you know however your
life or afterlife carries on after you
die I think is in accordance to how you
live this life I think a girl think you
can just be a murderer and then you know
die and then have something super dope
happy well I think a great example of
that is um the idea of Hell really kind
of like was painted in a really kind of
helpful picture to me when I watched the
American Horror Story season of coven
and when you died and you went to
it was basically just like a never
ending scene of like you you're out like
the most miserable place on earth but
that's your after analyst long loop it's
like so if you hate the DMV so much you
die
and you're in the DMV forever and that's
your hell it's like the infinite loop of
you your worst nightmare and I think I
think that is like one of the most kind
of vivid pictures I've ever had of like
what hell could be or what the afterlife
could be for someone who has done wrong
boy I mean you spend a little while in
church you'd have a different picture of
Hell my nose fiery pain brain and I've
heard some of that you know because
that's like that's the movie hell that's
the hell people talk about you know
whatever should we move on in this one
okay this one is called the universe
ends theory okay I think I'm part of
this one think of grand theft auto okay
you're in a specific location and
everything is right in front of you okay
you can see it like it's right there
when you're not in that location that
part of the world disappears hmm it only
comes up when it needs to got it so it's
like if a tree fell in the forest would
anyone hear it yes but the trees or tree
a tree even there so the idea that
you're truly the only person in the
universe and everyone else is a figment
of your world which is called I think
saw lips ISM event that would mean that
when you die the universe ends all
together because you have been this room
in show yeah Truman Show the the idea
that you're the only person you know I
feel like a lot of people have talked to
and I always thought that I was only one
who thought this but when you're kid you
like I wonder if I'm the only real
person here you know what everyone else
is just part of this big thing which is
the trim and shell but solipsistic where
it's like and I believe that's the right
term if I'm not correct to me but I
think it is where it's like everywhere
you go everything you do everyone you
meet every experience you have it's all
about you hmm
and so not like right now if that's the
case
nothing is behind me nothing is down the
street nothing you know is a crossover
see and it doesn't it's exactly so that
when you die the whole universe I'm not
buying into that one either another
month that seems like an incredibly
nervous assistant
but that's not a statistic but it's also
it's less like it's less ignorant I
agree yeah right it's less ignorant than
thinking that the humans are the only
species to I mean it's not wrong and
that you know everything is a projection
of your consciousness you know like I
get that yeah that part yeah and that
you can have it be a not narcissistic
thing it's just you know what exists
yeah but like if you let if you lived
your life dictated on that idea
that'd be so [ __ ] up it would be
[ __ ] up but it's an interesting
thought to have especially when I don't
know like when like when you meet
someone and they say something and
you're like wait how did you know that
or like why are you saying that you know
I mean like what what means you live in
in the Germans exactly like were you
scripted to say that are you a robot
here that's just like I'm I was supposed
to hear that sentence today and now
you're just saying it to me like that's
loud
that's [ __ ] weird I'm not buying into
that one or not mm-hm
I'm pretty much kind of not buying into
that one anyway alright this one is
called the life starts over again theory
pretty self-explanatory okay your whole
life could have just been deja vu and
you continue living in that same life
until you die similar to Groundhog Day
no oh God wait so you just keep living
in the same like okay clarify is that
like the same decade or whatever that
you're born the same like time
experience you're just like reliving
your entire life over and over yeah like
your whole like you've already lived
your life and every second of your day
of your life now is deja vu of your life
now you already lived and died okay so
or not that maybe it's just like you're
living in a deja vu reality like you're
living in a memory okay so I mean if
we're talking like parallel universes
and whatever you are infinite you would
just live your same life in a parallel
universe over and over and over and over
hmm I think so so when you die you just
you wake up in another universe and so I
mean well that would explain parallel
universes and
realities like that and why sometimes
you have deja vu and yeah that being
yeah realities so if you're just living
your same life over and over and over
again and you have deja vu about
something it's because you've done it in
a past life that I've literally already
live that's crazy you've said that to me
before that I blew my mind the reason
for days I do is that you're not the
reason it's very ya know that that
theory you've said to me it's like deja
vu means you just relive something that
you've done in the past right which is
crazy a parallel universe or a parallel
universe exactly but cuz deja vu is so
[ __ ] trippy I love data I love it I
love it too it's so wild to me how like
that feeling it's like so real yeah like
I've 1,000% experienced everything
that's happening I love deja vu because
I personally like to think that if I
have deja vu it means that I'm on the
right path like if I if I feel like I've
done something or something going around
me I've already experienced I'm like
that means I'm doing something right
right now like I'm on the right path
when I don't have deja vu for a little
while I get kind of nervous that I'm
making bad you actually get nervous if
you don't do it before well yeah I get
to it's like a job who doesn't like
scare me or jar me like I know some
people really don't like it yeah I feel
like if it's not happening to me I need
to work harder to make sure I'm doing
the right things I know that's like
super out of [ __ ] well it's loopy
duty you know it's out there but it's
interesting well I feel like because I
had like some of those experiences that
I call like power of the universe times
have had those my mom has had them and I
believe in a lot of that stuff just
universe [ __ ] and weird [ __ ] cosmic
whatever yeah even I feel like if I
don't have those moments of like an
explainable sort of cosmic interaction
or some weird bizarre universe stuff I
feel like I'm I'm disconnecting from
like a higher self you know I'm getting
too caught in my matrix and I need to
like yo let my soul get free because
then once I do that I have more of those
DejaVu experiences and more so you
notice a difference well yeah and so you
I feel like I have to actively be like
alright I need to you know get
disconnected
from the treadmill of life that I'm on
and then I have more of those
experiences the more open I am to them
happening in life being like a nice
easygoing you're paying attention to
living truer to what you're about rather
than what life is about right yeah you
can't get trapped in that stuff because
then I feel like you don't have those
experiences because you're closed off to
the universe and does it feel like safer
it feels better it was it was a very
bizarre thing for me to get used to
yeah you know but then once I am I'm
like this this feels good this feels
right I'd rather have these weird
experiences than feel disconnected and
trapped in the rat race of being alive
yeah do you mean oh absolutely
um the rat race that's a good way
because your pressure to live a certain
way to make money to live to write to be
compare your slave to this exactly when
you like body when you realize you need
to kind of step out of that well yeah
what is your purpose on earth and
sometimes I feel like your purpose on
earth is self-actualization Who am I
would what is my soul what do I have to
learn in this lifetime to become the
best version of myself and you know your
your place in the universe
yeah and that's not your job every day
your job every day is to make sure that
you survive stay alive you know
procreate whatever it is until you get
distracted from your true purpose yeah
you know I mean it's it takes time to
tap into it and energy to tap in that's
cool because then maybe you just keep
living your same life until you actually
take the time to self actual yes you
know wow that's a comforting thought
though what like you need to stay true
to what you're about otherwise you're
not living the right life mmm it's like
it's comforting well yeah if you if you
live the same life over and over and
over again maybe the universe doesn't
let you escape that Groundhog Day that's
all right until you live the lifetime
where you live it right you know what I
mean I would say that's comforting well
that's what I think that's why I get
nervous when I don't have these like
deja vu and like cosmic things I'm like
I'm missing something I'm not doing
something right I need to adjust myself
yeah you know you know what else is
comforting though black ring video
doorbell feels like
to make sure that you will not have a
home burglary ever because you have a
camera on your doorbell ring video
doorbell system has been proven to stop
burglaries before they happen guys
it is awesome we've been using it for
months and we get like a nice little
jingle an icicle gee it sounds like a
wind chime front door yeah yeah it's a
really cool notification there's push
notifications to your phone and their
advanced motion detection technology
protects your entire property with not
only just the ring video doorbell kit
but the ring of security kit which comes
with I believe it comes with this right
here which is a solar panel so you never
have to plug in your ring and then you
have doorbell which is awesome the the
stick up cam is part of the ring a
security kit which basically means you
have the camera on the doorbell so
you're seeing what your front door but
you have a stick up cam to put kind of
wherever you want your back door or your
side door somewhere where you know
people wouldn't expect surveillance and
you have a full 360 degree protection of
your house the weatherproof HD camera is
awesome because when you click on the
notification you get to see a live feed
and they even have cloud recording so if
you're not home and you can't click on
it it will record what it's all do
there's two-way audio you can talk to
someone at your door it's it's truly
like peace of mind in in a in a system
it's like every time we leave town and
we hear that jingle we're like oh who's
at the door it's like probably dog
Center and also you know when your post
Nate is here before you post mate is
even texting you Oh true so true what a
great point right now you guys get a
conscious your backyard any package
watch 2k16 big time you get 150 bucks
off the ring of security kit for the
dink family and after put a ring comm
slash Jenna Julian right now that's ring
comm / - and Julian highly recommend it
awesome system kind of a priceless
little investment you're making with
that our other sponsor this week is
texture guys thanks to pizza we're binge
eating thanks to Netflix we are binge
watching and now thanks to texture we're
going to be being reading
anyone who loves magazines but realizes
how incredibly outdated the system of a
magazine is this is for you you get all
the magazines and wine trees and what
super convenient place and you save the
trees
it's really cool because the texture app
lets you tap in the world's most popular
magazines and you can go through all
your favorite magazines while they also
curate magazine and certain articles
that you would like based on the ones
you've read before I'm a big fan of
Men's Fitness men's health anything from
Bon Appetit - eating well - I just pick
all the food ones but it's really really
easy you get on your phone your tablet
through the texture app right now
texture is offering the ding Pham a free
trial by going to texture comm slash
Jenna Julianne you'll gain immediate
entry to all of the top magazines
including back issues and bonus video
content start binge reading for free
right now and you go to texture comm /
annejulien it's texture calm / Jenna
Julian try it out and let us know what
you think oh yeah I know for a while
before I started texture I missed
magazines because I was like I don't
ever read magazines unless I'm at the
dentist's anymore and those are always
like taken up kid and at the nail salon
they have [ __ ] from like 2009 at nail
salons they just never just get texture
what if they had texture and just put it
on the iPads not an else'll I'm sure
there's nice ones around here that do
have them second awesome texture stick
is pretty sick them
thanks sponsors thank you sponsors
moving on to you make more than one
podcast bug we I don't know someone
Michael yeah and we actually have
somewhere to be like after an hour this
so we're only able to dip record for an
hour right now so the part two will
definitely happen for sure okay this one
is called you wake up from a dream
theory okay mmm okay the idea that your
whole life is a dream state suspended
from a different reality Oh like the
matrix sort of yeah but yeah because
you're plugging in so basically the true
reality that you're in is potentially
like millions of years ahead of where
you're now living in a futuristic time
right and so when you die we are little
capsules your capsule space caps
something yeah exactly
yeah and then when you die you just wake
up from being plugged into this reality
and I guess the question about this is
like
like maybe maybe the reason you plugged
in millions of years in the future to
this time 2016 is because your
civilization needed needed to do
research on what went down to solve some
sort of futuristic issue right I mean
maybe that's maybe that's the thing oh
yeah
or maybe there it's for a higher purpose
maybe they're they're culturing these
people to have these different lifetimes
which you know if time is relative maybe
there were giant beings or something in
you know whatever time goes by much
differently than it does for us so it
feels like actual lifetimes that we're
living but we would wake up from this
dream in ten minutes and go I know
kung-fu
like you know neo style but maybe they
need these people to live hundreds of
lifetimes in order to be wise enough to
exist in their current world so we were
like these gummy little babies that they
plug into matrixes to go oh and it's in
real time yeah to go live all of these
lifetimes in order to be cultured enough
to live in their existence so the
craziest part about that theory to me is
that I buy it just because of the fact
that when you actually meet that I could
totally believe and I believe it but I
believe it because it's similar to the
days of it like I feel like there's a
sensation that humans including myself
experience and you know what it feels
like so that it translates directly the
theory like for instance you said when
you have a very long dream right it
seems like you've gone and but you know
hours and hours and days and done all
this stuff and you wake up you're like
unto it in naps for 10 minutes yeah
right so that's that idea that you're
living a long period of time and it
really is just in reality that much time
I feel like that's that's something I
can I can get on the get on board right
well I think another good example
there's lots of good example of the
relativity of time but so we've been
waiting for how long now for you know
all of our God's from the sky to come
back cross-culturally we're all waiting
for you know Christ to come back all of
what I don't know whatever no yeah
everyone's sort of waiting because all
of their gods told them that they'd come
back mm-hmm and that was you know
thousands of years ago
and and whoever these sky being people
gods whatever could have literally in
their minds flown to the planet done
some [ __ ]
they've been gone for two weeks they
went and had family with their dinner
with their family and then they're like
I gotta go back to my big baby plan and
this is giant and we're like we're like
we made nukes and like we've done all
this stuff where people we've been
waiting for generations for you and
they're like dude we just left for like
five minutes okay like [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
it's only been since like the Stone Age
calm down shel guys that's crazy right
Wow
I like that one well because we'll think
of like Jesus or whatever right so Jesus
died and Jesus would come back mm-hmm
Jesus is still Jesus even though it's
been 2,000 years maybe for him he's
living in the future maybe he's only
like 40 years old now
hey Jesus years I don't know just throw
it out there no one is getting offended
by this by the way it's really not meant
to be I feel either getting a bit about
this podcast of all of our podcasts like
come on go far go get offended by like
one of the other podcast yours yeah grab
him right by the [ __ ] ipod [ __ ] death
is an illusion theory okay all right
buckle up I'm buckled since time is not
linear we just perceive it that way
right it would be possible that
everything that has already happened and
will ever happen currently exists
somewhere but we can't see it from where
we are parallel universe the universe
then the future in this theory could be
right next to you like right adjacent to
the present just on a different like
universe so when you die you realize
that death is an illusion because you
never really die there's a future
there's a past as a present but they're
all coexisting at all times okay there's
no end to life because it's not linear
it's cyclical and that means that every
event that is ever and always happening
sorry it means that every event ever is
always happening and never ends okay so
that includes like this moment right
this this moment is forever going to be
happy
but if you jump over the next universe
of a parallel universe
the moment were you born is happening
okay right it's not doesn't start and
end it's just yeah what do you think
that that's not the most far-fetched
thing you'll ever hear basically the
parallel universe yeah so you would just
you never really die never really died
you when you die you basically you are
brought to be aware of parallel
universes by seeing the fact that you
die and now you're like okay this has
been happening the whole time so as
March 20th 1995 and so as you know I
mean all these dates are always
happening yeah it's not the most
ridiculous I mean it's pretty straight
forward and it's like it's one of those
things were so you can't really be like
no [ __ ] no that's not the case
because you don't know you don't know no
idea have you done in me like specific
um but research looking into the
parallel universe theory ever because
it's something I would be interested in
looking in tomorrow I mean a little bit
not too much I have a good understanding
of it but that's about it
look I also try not to make myself
completely crazy cuz you know how I get
when I go down these holes I'll let it
like consume me as a person which is
dangerous yeah cuz then I can't function
what's crazy to me about this theory is
like the decisions you haven't made yet
are already made mm-hmm like tomorrow is
already in some universe that has
already been lived and every every
mathematical possibility of everything
that could ever been chosen or done or
did is being done is being done all the
time yet Wow weird but then then it begs
the questions like do you does anything
you do have an effect on it or are you
just like living this predetermined life
that you really don't have any control
over it's like it's perceived control
just receive control but everything that
can ever happen has already happened I
mean that's terrifying but it's also
kind of like I can't do any more on a
relaxing yeah it's like II can't really
[ __ ] up because it's already done yeah
what else you got there should be [ __ ]
I'm just trying to think you want me to
read you snow no I got one more I go
okay um okay this one's crazy you are
already dead theory no they already died
and maybe you're experiencing your life
again because it needs to be reviewed
maybe because your life may have been
reconstructed in a simulator because the
futures and people are looking into the
past to solve a problem they're facing
someone or the other one right or this
life could be a recreation of the past
you could have been dead for centuries
oh it makes you feel icky the simulation
is the only thing that made you relive
or live this life maybe we have already
collected all the information that our
life has to offer but we don't actually
experience it until we die so that means
we're all currently dead
icky I don't like that at all I don't
like thinking that I'm dead because I
died because I died oh my god well I
mean but what do you think of it though
yeah I mean it relates to the other I
don't back it relates to the other one
you know I get that maybe we're our
actual physical self is not a human
being in any shape or form and that
we're being projected into this
consciousness I think that's a
possibility but I just don't like it
makes me feel icky but the idea that
your life like the idea that your life
is over and you're currently reliving a
life that you are no longer living for
for simulation purposes or whatever is
creepy in and of itself because it's
like and we're talking about so how many
is this right like imagine if that
really is the case and we're sitting
here talking about it while we're
already dead like it oh my thought at
all that makes me feel gross okay we can
move on
Thanks what do you got I got one called
Lenz's theory of biocentrism and the
afterlife hell yeah this was cool like
there's a whole big article on it that I
didn't read all of which I like I don't
care but it's classes the theory of
everything and comes from the Greek for
life center is the belief that life and
biology are central to reality and that
life creates the universe not the other
way around
so how did the universe come to
existence
if life creates universe did life just
exist in all our consciousness our
consciousness makes sense of the world
and can be altered to change this
interpretation so we all think right
like the universe existed and then life
existed not we all think that's a
terrible thing to say you can think
whatever you want or you have thought
whatever you want but instead because
life exists the universe exists so when
you die so does the universe mm-hmm or
when everything dies so does the
universe so not just you it has to be
everything yeah I guess that's cool it's
a cool idea but I found some other
things this is a little different
I'm ready for this [ __ ] hit me these are
different beliefs of what happens after
you die this is called the vici you
ready actually not the musician although
now I think very differently the
musician Buddhism puts an interesting
spin on the afterlife since there's no
singular being or group of beings
controlling your fate or judging your
actions your ultimate destiny boils down
to Karma you're in control based on what
you do with your life Naraka the
Buddhist equivalent to hell is broken
into a series of realms based on the
severity of one's bad karma
the worst is avicii avicii is a massive
cube structure buried deep beneath the
ground to get there one must have
committed at least one of the five great
offenses in a nutshell murdering your
parents or someone holy Oh ready one of
the most unique aspects of avicii is
that your time there is only temporary
though it is very long times eons and
suffering is constant once you've worked
through your bad karma you're reborn on
a higher realm however you can die on
avicii though doing so just causes you
to be reborn in the VG oh my god
also unlike hell a VG isn't seen
strictly as some sort of spiritual
punishment though certainly you
certainly don't want to wake up there
it's better viewed as a sort of
spiritual cleansing interesting in that
crazy that's really interesting so like
if I just like chill the random dude I
don't know what else killed their mom
yeah we're not in the same hell
but we're both in that place yeah I mean
it's interesting that like I understand
murdering someone holy like that's I get
that across religions but just murdering
your parents is like deemed the worst
thing because it's like killing the
people who made you hated you yeah wael
great world okay
this one is called the chin VAT bridge
you may not have heard I'm reading all
of this it's from weird warm calm weird
wormy may not have heard of Zorro stray
and sysm whatever before but at one
point it was one of the largest
religions on the planet Zoroaster rands
ism there are two possibilities for your
afterlife mirroring that of heaven and
hell but before you find either one you
must cross the chin VAT bridge or the
bridge of judgement those who are you
Judgment Day
yeah those who lead a good life the
bridge is easily passable broadening as
they progress and leading them to the
house of song to spend an eternity of
peace sinners however must watch the
bridge as it turns on its side and
becomes narrow like a razor then a
hideous woman appears to torment them
until they fall off the bridge into the
House of Lies the House of Lies is
something straight out of nightmares
those inside must eat rotten food or
flesh and are continuously tormented
while they do so also despite being
crowded to maximum capacity each person
is trapped inside and feels as though
they are completely isolated
however the House of Lies is similar to
Avicii and that it's not the final
resting place for the wicked eventually
you're granted entry to the house of
song presumably after you fully
understand just what a raging douche you
were in life Wow
holla holla isn't exactly a punishment
so as is the end of the line folks don't
leave there's a lesson to be learned and
no one ever
and nearly everyone but mythological
heroes find themselves there so it's a
bit of a downer in Babylonian mythology
or kala was the world where the dead
existed one kept their body but it's
still decomposed oh my god to get your
final destination you must travel
through a series of
seven gates first you're probably
thinking I'm not too keen on doing that
or indeed being in this terrible place
and that's all well and good but you
have no choice there are guards posted
at every gate to ensure that you follow
the correct path and just because each
one takes an article of clothing jewelry
or whatever possession you may have had
on your person when you die because hey
you're dead Wow
things don't exactly improve once you're
inside the final gate everyone is forced
to consume only dust inside the massive
dark expanse oh my allergies would be
terrible seriously there's no Satan
esque figure to torture you or indeed
any actual punishment you just kind of
hang out neat dust while you're rotting
this apparently is supposed to be a
parallel to the living world Oh shadow
world like did demagogy yeah we're
guessing the world was a vastly
different place in the 6th century hmm
that's so sad imagine being like all
right I'm gonna die man pass on to dust
world to go eat dust while I watch
myself decompose [ __ ] no thank you watch
myself decompose and that was a big
belief in Babylonian ministry [ __ ] me up
the thought of like out-of-body death
like watching your body die like that
her decomposed is cringe right I mean
you hear all these people saying like
yeah I've died I came back to life I saw
the afterlife I'm inexperienced I did
this I did that like people have all
different kinds of things I've never
heard anyone be like yeah I sat in a
room and ate dust yeah well I definitely
like a new thing that I've never heard
what one can I just like start something
on one of the things that I like really
always hated the thought of this is it's
morbid but it's it's more like sad is
that like the thought of dying and being
able to like watch in on the people who
are just miserable because you died mmm
like you know when people say like oh
she's watching over us like I get that
but it's like if you're if you're dead
and you died and say like like a kind of
an unexpected way and you're now just
sitting there like in a room watching a
TV screen of all the people who are left
like mourning yeah
that's like that to me is their worst
thing ever like the best possible
afterlife for me is something that has
culminated throughout your whole life
and it is something new and it's not
like dwelling on the fact that you just
died yeah and kind of just circling
around the fact that now you're dead
only on this world like ideally it would
be like morphing into some next Park and
whatever everything is do you think
they're ghosts cuz I believe a hundred
percent in ghosts okay and I like to
think that ghosts are people that
haven't passed on like this unfinished I
think those exist but I think we should
do an entire podcast on ghosts I agree
that should be its own thing but yeah
it's I think it's a good idea to bring
up the fact that we've brought this up
another podcast but the short story the
egg where a guy dies and he goes to
heaven and he meets God and and he's
like what do I do what happens I'm dead
now and gods like sort of laughing and
babying him when everyone be like oh you
know you're good guy and then he's like
well what happened found he's like I'm
sending you back he's like well what do
you mean like reincarnated he's like
well sort of he's like uh you you are
the only person that there is you go and
you live every single legend you're
everyone that there's ever been and ever
will be just you or does so that you do
it until you learn everything your every
single person he's like so you mean I'm
Hitler and he's like yeah and you're all
the Jews that he killed and you just go
and you you live one lifetime at a time
that's a great story
damn spoiler alert so you're that guy
that catfish that one girl and you're
the girl who got catfished by that one
guy and you're all the girls you checked
out and you're those girls boyfriend
exactly but I mean if you if you ever
sit and think about right that way
doesn't that change the way um maybe you
already think this but it would in
theory change the way that you treat
everybody you know or if you are that
self-centered person that was like
everything's about me there is no
anything there's nothing else you sort
of treat people however the [ __ ] you
want because nothing [ __ ] matters
like you the type of person she's gonna
go murder everyone on the street cuz you
just don't think anyway you're just
murdering and mistreating yourself stuff
Wow
I like that third right it's cool that's
called the egg theory no no it's a short
story the egg is called as the title
why's it called egg cuz you're an egg
like is it cuz
I know why is it called no tummy what is
that name someone just like oh it
finishes great story nobody call I don't
know I'm hungry let's call an egg let's
go alright this is called Jehan num if
anyone knows why that's called egg
please let you know I'm kind of
frustrated out I'm sure you have some
symbolism but I don't want to think
about it right now like you you're being
born you're an egg that's a your we
weren't born eggs my god we're not Birds
jahannum jahannum is easily explained as
the quran equivalent to hell but it's a
little more complicated than that
punishment is based on how one lived
their life see anytime where something's
like cross cultural cross religion like
okay let's not yet let's not deny that
this happens around the world then has
for centuries and I realize people been
around it's a thing like how people have
wars of religion but they get along over
this well like think about before
there's communications between these
gigantic continents how did someone in
you know rural China have the same
beliefs as like Native Americans in
America like some of it so you know
crazy that's like when we talk about
ancient aliens and [ __ ] and there's like
pyramids all over the world with using
the same sort of techniques like how how
[Music]
okay anyways punishment is based on when
how the one lived their life and only
the most severe are captain Jung
jahannum for eternity jahannum janym
janym the most severe sin is the
worshipping of multiple gods interesting
a running theme in Johanna's punishments
is it'll get better promise ordinary
polytheism right yeah for example one
punishment is to have the skin of your
body burned off regenerated and burned
off again fireplace nice fireplace okay
came back yes again fireplace a pretty
big role in things from being dragged
through fire having to wear clothes made
of flame burning organs the beat goes on
the person who's being punished the
least since all relative to the life you
leave lead will have their brain boiled
from standing on hot coals okay try
that rat through fire okay okay if
you're looking to customize your
horrible otherworldly experience simply
commit suicide the object you chose to
end your life will torture you on the
day of judgment in jug jog jog uh Nam
know there's a pretty solid chance it
will be on fire for the last bit do it
okay just do it super fun okay this is
called die you die you comes from
Chinese mythology the result of Buddhist
beliefs mixing with different Chinese
folk religions die is similar to Nakara
mentioned in the first century and that
it contains multiple hell's but in a
nutshell die you is a massive
underground maze how deep beneath the
earth with different levels or chambers
or yes I can't talk with this I [ __ ]
with this though specifics vary most
most beliefs contend that die you is
only temporary but everyone serves their
time there with no exception I would
kill value I would wreck right through
every level of you so good I would want
to stay there though just like play
games mazes the chambers that contain
each aisle are guarded by a judge and
contain oddly specific punishments for
example the mountain of knives is
exactly what you think it is sinners are
forced to climb the mountain and destroy
their own bodies in the process but they
can't get to the top they just die on
the way up the grinding machine is again
exactly what it says on the label
there's also the world of ice where you
are frozen and succumb to frostbite just
in case you weren't having a bad enough
time being tortured there's a kicker you
can die again should you give it up to
the spirit in the sky a second time
you'll simply be reborn in whatever hell
killed you the first time this happens
an infinite number of times until your
soul is purified and you are recorded in
a higher realm okay but imagine if there
was like a live feed of this world and
you could just like watching movies at
which channel oh my sick Julian see oh
that guy got pretty far on the mountain
Ives like I [ __ ] with him you know
what's the sickest part about die and
come back you know well you know what
the sickest part about what you just
said is that would be the biggest
channel on twitch oh you'd kill it
because not in the donations giant or
they go though are they build another
mountain of knives chain better not a
knife sharpener for full time knife
start prepping or join insurance Julie
what sorry well I think this is a good
discussion and as always please let us
know your thoughts on these like and if
we if we missed any that are pretty
paramount well yeah nutrient it
definitely did maybe just like tweet us
um let's just plan on doing apart to do
this podcast eventually I'm gonna do
ghost will do ghost podcast that's a
good one
I'm like obsessed with some of those
that's a good one you've seen ghost I
move let's talk about their but the
thing about ghosts for me is like it's
one of those things where I had this
belief my whole life I'm like no [ __ ]
way [ __ ] you they're not real and then a
couple of experiences whether it's
myself experienced things or talking to
people who I trust kept kind of changed
my thoughts so real so I think we would
have a really good discussion there so
real Piru so real I like you know when
people are so super skeptical of it and
then you know you take them somewhere
and they have that experience and you
just watch their little gears grind like
trying to explain it you're like not
dude you can't yeah you cannot explain
what just happened here yeah you there
Mythbusters whatever let not Mythbusters
Ghost Hunters I love the way that they
do do that show or did in the past when
it was like a very scientific way to
approach it like yeah we don't need to
freak out but they definitely have those
times where you just can't [ __ ]
explain it the fact that those exist
around the world cross culturally every
day all the time
come on man there's just [ __ ] things
in the world that you can't explain
huh alright so for the for the ghost
podcast are we going to like obviously
we're gonna bring our own stories we're
gonna bring our thoughts but we should
also do some research on what what's out
there and see ghosts Oh Gabi gay love a
good one yeah we just came up with a
podcast idea on a podcast what that's
some dink fan magic right there dink
dink dink Thank You dink family love you
so much thank you for hanging out with
us for another week yeah we love you
we love you very much and we'll see you
next week perhaps for a ghost podcast
we'll have a cool background for that
one make sure you check out all the
sponsored links in the description below
ring video doorbell system and texture
really great things both of them and we
highly recommend them we can probably do
another podcast about other things
happens when you die because there's so
many things we will and so Jenna at
Jenna Julianne pod on Twitter if you
guys are not following hop on that
Twitter and we respond Debby responds
we're always on that thing at taking
ideas and requests and we just kind of
love your feedback on the podcast so if
you have you know for instance if you
have some death after death theories
their afterlife there is a lot of stuff
yeah Peter Maass and we appreciate y'all
well you guys have a good week have a
good Monday yeah yeah damn
[Music]